Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still
blazing a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
We took a huge chance.
I quit a full‐time job.
...by working smart...
Who here would like to help us
refine the gentleman?
...by thinking big...
BoomBoom is intended for intense
refreshment and rejuvenation.
...and chasing their dreams.
My dream is want to come America
to be a fashion designer.
Narrator: And tonight,
legendary NBA star
and investor Charles Barkley
joins the Tank.
Barkley: Anytime
it comes to investing,
you're really investing
in people.
You seem to be
on the right track,
and I'm willing
to take the chance.
Your margins suck.
I think your valuation
is gonna need a haircut.
Whoo!
First into the tank
is a product line
for today's refined modern man.
♪♪
[ Foreign accent ]
Hi, my name is Steve King,
and this is my son...
[ Foreign accent ]
Josh King.
And we're from
San Diego, California.
Our company
is Manscaped,
and we're here today looking
for $500,000 for 7%.
‐7%?
‐7%?!
‐Whoo!
‐Wow.
Sharks, it's time
to talk about it.
Forget about the beard oils
and the hair creams.
When it comes
to male grooming,
there's more to a man
than meets the eye,
for what goes on
below the neck and the waist
can be ignored
no longer.
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
At Manscaped,
we're dedicated to beautifying
and refining what truly
makes a man a man.
We have crafted the only kit
you would ever need
to practice proper lawn care.
[ Laughter ]
When it comes for regions
left neglected
for far too long,
we give you...
The Lawn Mower 2.0.
A trimmer powerful enough
to cut through
any unruly shrubbery
with abandon.
[ Blows ]
[ Laughter ]
As you can see,
when you trim the hedges,
the tree stands taller.
[ Laughter ]
Besides trimming
and shaping the hedges,
the first rule
of manscaping is...
Wash thy bits!
[ Laughter ]
And there's no better way
than with our specially
formulated hygiene bundle.
These pH‐balanced solutions
help hydrate and replenish
an area too often forgotten
and left in the dark.
They're tough
on funk and chafe
whilst being delicate
on your delicates.
So, who here would like to help
us refine the gentleman?
Charles wants to be a demo.
Charles wants to demo.
Perfect packages
for your perfect packages.
You need to show Charles
how it works.
‐Thank you.
‐Of course.
Josh: Lori.
Thank you.
Just to be clear,
it's not for the area here.
It's just for the area...
Correct. It's below‐the‐waist
grooming and hygiene.
The Plow ‐‐
oh, my gosh.
Absolutely.
Wait ‐‐ [ Laughing ]
Wait a minute!
We have really crafted
the only kit you would ever need
to literally get started
from a manscaping position.
Cuban: So, wait, all of America
and the world wants to know ‐‐
Charles, do you manscape?
Not a day in my life.
[ Laughter ]
So, how did you
get into this?
[ Laughter ]
Josh: Well, one night,
I was having some drinks
with my friends.
We started talking about
manscaping horror stories
where maybe we were
getting ready for dates,
and it didn't work out
'cause we were using
the wrong tools for the job.
Every man is manscaping.
Nobody knows what they're doing.
Josh, how many percentage of men
are manscaping down there?
Back in 2008,
it was about 6%.
Today, it's 73%.
‐73%?
So, there's been
a dramatic increase.
What caused that?
The Millennial
metrosexual movement of men
wanting to take care
of themselves.
What's your background?
Josh: I graduated college
in 2010,
I spent the last five to six
years in digital agencies
and in the start‐up
environment,
learning more SEO and
the ins and outs of e‐commerce.
After having that night, the
fateful night with my friends,
I brought the insights
to my pops.
After we dove into
the market,
found it was
a $3 billion industry,
he introduced me
to chemists and engineers,
and that's when
we started working on
the first eight items
of our Perfect Package.
So, y'all are
father and son?
Yes.
Yes, we are.
So, you used to have
hair that good?
Sadly, yes.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Josh, why did you go
to your pops?
My pops is, um, my idol.
Oh, that's awesome.
He's a very successful
businessman.
I wouldn't be where
I am without him.
‐Aww.
‐That's great.
O'Leary: Okay, guys, let's
focus on the task at hand.
$7.1 million valuation.
That's a lot of hair
down there.
[ Laughs ]
So, 2017, we finished off
the year and did $1.5 million.
‐Good for you!
‐Wow!
We launched
in January 2017.
It took us about
four months to work out
how to message
our target market.
And so we actually almost walked
away and closed the business.
We just couldn't
get it going.
Then we discovered
we should try humor.
Humor would appeal and be able
to resonate with our audience.
So, we had 3,000 sets,
these kits,
and we went
back to market in April
and we sold out
in 13 days.
‐13 days?
‐And so, what was the message?
And what does it cost?
Where did you do
this marketing?
What was the humor?
We plucked all the stories
that I sat around that table
with my friends and turned them
into live videos,
and we're at
48 million video views.
‐Wow!
‐48 million?
Yeah, yeah.
How much is this bag?
A whole kit you have
in your hands is $51.
Wow, that's a great price.
What's your cost
to make them?
$12.
But, you know, isn't $51
an odd price point?
Wow, that's great.
That's the average
order value.
Oh, okay. So, if I were
to buy this kit, though ‐‐
So, you have other choices?
Yeah, so you would go ‐‐
You don't have to buy
the whole kit.
Oh, I can buy
individual components?
You can get just ‐‐
Yeah, we try to get you
into a kit first
so that you can
experience the products,
and then we want you to
replenish and come back and ‐‐
That's not a bad price,
though.
How much are you gonna make
on the $1.5 million?
We lost ‐‐ in that year
for $1.5 million,
we lost $133,000.
I'm gonna assume because
your margins aren't big enough
on this to pay for your
customer acquisition cost?
We'd be reinvesting
every penny.
I probably put
about $400,000 ‐‐
The question with this ‐‐
I mean, let's get down
to the business model,
because there's
nothing proprietary
about putting razor blades
and perfumes into a bag
and selling it online.
The whole business now is what's
your customer acquisition cost
versus the margin
of the bag.
What does it cost you to acquire
a customer ‐‐ new customer?
So, right now, customer
acquisition cost is $16.
What's the margin
on the bag?
Right now,
about $7 per kit.
That sucks.
So, why is it
$16 per acquisition?
So, year to date,
we've done $2.1 million.
We would've made about
$60,000 to $80,000 per month,
but we put all that money
back into inventory
and into paid media.
So on our paid media,
any one month,
we spend anywhere between
$120,000 or maybe $150,000 ‐‐
Otherwise known
as advertising.
Both: Yes.
‐Okay.
‐Got it.
So, for every dollar that
we spend on paid media,
we're trying to generate
$2.50 of revenue.
Greiner: Do women
buy this product?
‐Yes.
‐For men, yeah.
It's probably not a heavily
gifted item from women.
No, I think
it's the other way,
'cause it's a present
for the woman.
It really is.
[ Laughs ]
Seriously.
Women buying for men,
we found a huge lift
in the holiday season,
especially around
November and December.
O'Leary: Okay, so, I look at it
from simply how do ‐‐
I put up $500,000, and I want
to get back $2 million.
That's the kind of
investment I'd want.
It's not clear to me
how this is gonna work,
and frankly, I think the model
isn't nailed down yet.
I'm out.
Charles,
what are you gonna do?
I ‐‐ Listen.
[ Sighs ]
Like I told you, I've never
manscaped in my life,
and I'm not starting now,
so I'm out.
Thank you.
Herjavec: All right, guys,
I've heard enough.
I think you have
an incredible brand.
You've got a great ‐‐ I don't
want to call it a shtick,
because it
undermines it, but ‐‐
It is shtick.
It's great, though.
Yeah, it's great.
It's a great marketing angle.
I do manscape. I was on
"Dancing With the Stars."
They made me get a wax,
and I just kind of went crazy.
Now I manscape
everywhere.
And I think
a lot of people do.
Was that a Brazilian?
[ Laughs ]
But the numbers scare me.
There's no way I'm giving you
$500,000 for 7%.
I would need a lot more.
What's your offer?
I think your valuation
is gonna need a haircut.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Robert is interested in Josh and
Steve's male‐grooming company,
Manscaped, but he wants
a bigger stake of the company
than the 7% they are offering.
I'll give you the $500,000,
but I'm gonna need,
at this early stage...
...35%.
Ooh!
O'Leary:
Yippie‐aye‐oh‐ki‐yay!
What are you doing, Lori?
Greiner:
So, when you first came in
before you started talking
and I just saw "Manscaped,"
I was thinking,
"Well, this probably is not
the product for me."
But, Lori...
Honestly, like, you know,
I'm just gonna talk about, like,
being careful with scissors
and get out, right?
[ Laughter ]
But your routine was fabulous ‐‐
funny as can be.
The accent
really boosts this.
It helps.
This is a lovely kit.
I see how the customer
could be women.
Mark said something
that was really interesting.
He said, "It's actually
for the women."
Technically, it is.
This is perfect for QVC!
I ‐‐ Really ‐‐
Lori, I'll put up the money just
to watch you sell it on QVC.
[ Laughs ]
Would you really?
All right,
if Mark is in $500,000,
I help sell it on QVC,
what's your offer?
Um...
He was kidding.
Yeah, well,
now I've trapped him.
♪♪
If Lori can sell it on QVC,
I'll put up the money,
but just having 7%
or even 10% or 15%,
that's just not enough, because
you guys will do what you do,
but Lori particularly
can add a whole new market,
particularly
selling to women.
And so Lori and I will offer
the $500,000 for 25%.
So your decision is
your 7% versus 25%.
That 18%, we'll more than
make that up in increased sales
and balance it all out.
Herjavec: Look,
that's a better offer.
Sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
Would you consider 20%?
No.
Because we'll make you more
and save you more
to more than
balance it all out.
I'm gonna find out if millions
of women want manscaping.
O'Leary:
Guys, most of us thought
when you stepped out here
with this presentation
the chance of you
walking out of the Shark Tank
with half a million dollars
was zero.
You have a real offer.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Guys, we will ‐‐
we will take that deal.
‐Deal!
‐Good!
[ Laughter ]
‐This is beautiful.
‐This is gonna be interesting.
Who would have thought?
‐Wow.
‐Congratulations.
‐It's amazing.
‐Congratulations, guys.
Lori, Lori, I think
the first guy we get to
test out the new products ‐‐
Charles.
Ain't no woman gonna leave me
'cause I don't
shave my [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Josh: We're agile
as it is right now,
but you add
two strategic players,
imagine how quickly
we're gonna solve issues.
I'm speechless.
[ Sighs ]
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
♪♪
I was born in Leeds, Alabama.
I was raised by my mother
and grandmother,
two of the greatest people ever.
My childhood was great because
we didn't know we were poor.
When I first started
playing basketball,
I just wanted to
go to college for free.
I never even thought about
playing in the NBA.
People actually told me I wasn't
good enough to play in the NBA,
and I proved them wrong.
So that's where
my drive came from.
I played in the NBA
for 16 years.
Those were the best
16 years of my life.
When I retired,
I got into broadcasting.
I get paid to watch basketball.
It's the greatest job
in the world.
Thank you, guys.
Can't wait.
You have to be really careful
when you give money
'cause you get 50 to 60
business proposals a month.
I have been very lucky that
I got screwed right off the bat.
My first agent stole my money,
and from that point on,
I've been very judicious
what I invest in.
What people don't talk about
is 80% of professional athletes
go broke.
I made up my mind ‐‐
I ain't never gonna be
one of those guys
that go broke ‐‐ ever.
I'm Charles Barkley.
I prefer to invest
with minorities ‐‐
blacks and Hispanics ‐‐
'cause I think they have
the hardest time getting money.
But it's not just minorities ‐‐
I want to help poor whites
who are in the same boat,
who don't have
the economic opportunity.
Entrepreneurship
is really important
because you give people power.
The power to control
your own life is a big deal,
and I love when
I work with people
and I give them that power,
where they can control
their own destiny.
When you grow up poor,
you have a moral obligation
to go back and bring as many
people along for the journey
with you as possible,
and that's what
I'm always going to do.
When I look at my life...
I can't believe it.
I've exceeded
all my expectations.
A little fat kid from
the projects of Leeds, Alabama,
grew up to be Charles Barkley.
That's pretty cool.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
a unique way to get refreshed.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks. I'm John Pinto,
and this is my better half.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Chelsea Pinto.
Our company's BoomBoom,
and we're seeking $300,000
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
Sharks, we have a new
best friend for your nose.
It's time to turn breathing
into money.
Think about it ‐‐
your eyes have eye drops,
your mouth has mouthwash,
and your lips have lip balm.
But there's not an everyday
healthy and safe product
for your nose to enjoy.
Introducing BoomBoom.
BoomBoom is
an all‐natural nasal inhaler
made of essential oils, menthol,
and other stimulating scents.
Most products for your nose
are for congestion or allergies.
BoomBoom is intended for intense
refreshment and rejuvenation.
Just unscrew the cap, place
the barrel inside each nostril,
and inhale
slowly but deeply.
[ Laughter ]
It's like gum for your nose,
but 10 times more minty‐fresh.
With each inhale,
you'll experience a cooling,
tingly sensation
that makes you feel alive.
So, Sharks,
who wants to invest
and get this business
booming?
‐I want to smell it.
‐Yeah.
Chelsea has some samples.
There's five scents.
Should I use it
and pass it down?
No, no, no, just...
[ Laughs ]
‐Thank you.
‐Which is the strongest one?
They're all similar
intensity.
Which is the most popular?
Tropical Rush
is our bestseller.
There's a base of menthol
and peppermint in all of them.
‐Whoo.
‐Whoo!
There you go.
‐Yeah, I love it!
[ Laughter ]
Yes!
That's really good!
It's really quite a hit.
It enhances
your breathing for ‐‐
It does open you up.
Think of it like a mint
for your nose.
There's so many
different uses.
I mean, for me, I love
to BoomBoom in the car,
going to work...
You like ‐‐
...you know,
after a long flight.
It's just refreshing.
Is there other products
like this?
There are two other
nasal inhalers,
but they're not fun
and vibrant like ours.
They have more of a medicinal,
kind of earthy smell to them.
What are your sales?
Last year,
we did $754,000 in sales.
‐Good for you.
‐What?!
And this year, we're on track
to do $1.1 million.
Wow!
Yeah.
People love this thing.
‐Wow.
And how are you selling?
Where are you selling?
It's primarily
direct‐to‐consumer
through our own website.
Oh, good for you.
That's even better.
And on Amazon.
What's the breakdown
between the two?
It's 20% direct‐to‐consumer,
30% through Amazon.
45% is wholesale
and other distributors.
Okay, you are doing
wholesale.
Yeah.
How much does it cost to make
one of these little inhalers?
That single pack right there
is 70 cents.
And what do you
sell it for?
We sell that on our website
for $7.95.
Wow.
You must be making
a ton of money.
Net profit last year was
$120,000 after I paid myself.
Where's it made at?
It's made in
southern California.
You couldn't reduce your costs
by going offshore?
To 69 cents.
At scale, we can bring
our costs down about 25%.
We want to make it
in the U. S.
Your cost is fine.
Because you're inhaling it,
we want to make sure
the ingredients are top‐notch.
And what's
your wholesale price?
Our wholesale price
is $1.50.
‐Ohh.
‐Oh, wow.
That's not a good margin.
Yeah, but ‐‐
Ooh, I like
the other margin.
Why did you do that?
Is it because you're concerned
that they'll put it out
at too high a price point?
So, we feel like the sweet spot
in retail is $3.99.
But you're selling it
for more than that on the site,
your own site.
But that ‐‐ Yeah.
You're undercutting yourself
at a lower margin.
I understand that,
but we've tested $3.99 to $5.99,
depending on the store.
‐And?
And $3.99,
it moves a lot quicker.
Is this y'all full‐time job?
Yes.
I'm actually a dentist,
so I do that part time.
That's why those smiles
are so nice.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
What's intriguing
is you're saying
that the retail price point
that works ‐‐
sub $4, $3.99 ‐‐
is basically half of what
you're putting it out
on your own store at...
right?
But you have to understand,
there's been no focus in retail.
Well, that's not
a sustainable model, John.
You can't do that
long‐term.
Why would I pay 8 bucks for it
when I can get it for $4?
It's a point‐of‐purchase
product. It really is.
No, I get that, but, John,
your margins suck in retail.
How do you cut the cost?
We sell wholesale
to $2, as well.
$1.50 to $2.
We have some customers
that pay up to $2.
Are y'all
50/50 partners?
So, I own a little over
36% of the company.
The other co‐founder
is the same amount,
and then we have
three other people who invested.
What value did they invest at?
And how much?
So, they invested
$200,000,
and they own
25% of the company.
You gave them 25%
for $200,000?
Correct.
You want $300,000
and give us 10%?
Yeah.
Well, there's value now
in the company. We have sales.
Yeah, but there's value
over here, too.
I did not think that
you'd be talking about
a million‐dollar year
when you came out here
with this thing,
'cause I've never
heard of it.
But now you want to play
in the big leagues,
and that is really expensive.
You know, I keep looking at it,
and I'm intrigued,
but there's no way I would
give you a $3 million valuation.
I'm out, guys.
Thanks.
You know, I was thinking,
you know,
maybe if it's in
your purse or whatever,
you go into
a public restroom,
sometimes
that's super unpleasant,
and I was thinking if you had
that and you used the BoomBoom.
Airplanes.
Airplanes, as well.
But $300,000 for 10%
for something that I'm concerned
is, like, a one‐time buy...
...just doesn't resonate,
so I'm out.
Well, I think this is
a really neat thing,
but it's not something I'm gonna
do on a consistent basis.
You being a dentist,
don't you quit that job.
[ Laughs ]
I'm gonna have to pass.
I'm out.
Thanks.
It's not that
the valuation's too high.
It's that your margins,
your net margins, are too low.
You know, particularly
if you're gonna go
so heavily to retail,
I just don't see that.
It's only gone marginally viral,
as opposed to,
hey, everybody's
picking it up.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thanks.
Hang on a sec.
[ Sniffs ] Wow!
I love it.          Yes, Robert.
I like it.
What's interesting to me is
all the Sharks liked it.
There were some concerns,
but nobody liked your valuation.
We must be tired
or something,
'cause we do have the ability
to change the valuation.
I see it
as a bit of a flyer.
It could go boom, boom,
or behh!
I'll give you the $300,000,
but I want to be in
where you're in ‐‐ 36%.
‐Ohh!
‐Ichi‐wawa caramba!
It's a flyer.
That means you're
no longer at 36%.
It's the valuation.
How do I get
to that $3 million?
I can't.
$300,000 for 36%.
John and Chelsea, I think
you asked for too much cash
in this deal ‐‐
that's the problem.
Everybody's trying
to contort the valuation.
Robert's the only guy
willing to take the risk.
What are you gonna do?
Unfortunately,
we can't ‐‐
I can't give up
that much equity.
Um...
What are you willing
to give up?
Would you be willing
to do 15%?
No. No.
I'm comfortable with 36%,
we do the $300,000,
and we smell our way
to the future.
I don't want to
negotiate down from that.
The highest
we can do is 20%.
Can't do it.
[ Clicks tongue ]
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you so much.
Honestly, this was amazing.
‐Thanks.
It's definitely a bummer
not getting a deal with Robert,
but that's not gonna stop us
from really making this happen.
We know there's a place
for BoomBoom,
and we look forward
to everybody trying it out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a sweet treat
inspired by
a popular diet trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Billie.
And I'm Holly.
Both:
And we're Cave Shake!
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange
for 10% of our company.
Have you ever tried
to cut sugar, carbs,
or gluten
from your diet...
Find you're hunting
at the grocery store,
then realize
it's in everything?!
Do you ever wake up,
eat your pancakes,
and then need a nap?
Because you crash
from all the carbs.
[ Laughs ]
Are you ever craving sweets
so badly,
you can't resist the urge
any longer and you melt down?
And binge on ice cream?!
[ Laughter ]
Both: Cave Shakes
to the rescue!
Ta‐da.
Cave Shakes are great
as a dessert, snack,
or meal replacement.
They're dairy‐free
and gluten‐free...
Super low‐carb...
...ready to drink...
...great for
pre‐ and post‐workouts...
...and a sweet treat
without the sugar.
So, Sharks...
♪ Don't you want
a Cave Shake? ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
take it to the gym day ♪
♪ Cave Shake ♪
[ Whistling ]
♪ Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
take it to a party ♪
♪ Cave Shake ♪
[ Whistling ]
♪ Sunday, Funday,
take it to your honey ♪
♪ Cave Shake ♪
♪ They taste great! ♪
Both: Cave in to a Cave Shake,
the treat without the cheat.
[ Greiner laughs ]
So, we heard
the Sharks love to eat.
We got some samples
for you.
‐Good.
‐Great.
Charles, you got to get up there
and do that dance.
Herjavec: Nice dance.
[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
‐♪ Cave Shake ♪
♪ Cave Shake ♪
We've got a sample
for everybody.
Lots of samples.
They're very filling.
There you go, Robert.
‐Okay.
‐Just grab one of these puppies?
And then we've got a full ‐‐
I'm gonna stand up
so I don't mess this up.
Sorry. They're a little hard
to grab there.
And then the full chocolate
is for you.
‐♪ Cave Shake ♪
It's a catchy song.
Billie: Charles, you have
the coffee here.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah, totally.
‐So, it's low in sugar, huh?
Holly: Low in sugar.
No sugar is added.
‐No sugar.
‐So, we have four flavors ‐‐
Ugh!
Oh, I hate it.
‐It's actually good.
Thank you.
I like it.
Why does it taste funny?
It's sweetened with stevia,
so if you're not
a stevia person,
that's probably
what you're tasting.
We get, like, one out of 100
that doesn't like stevia.
So, how many calories
in one of these?
The whole thing, 480.
480?
Yes.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be so concerned
with the calories...
[ Laughter ]
That's easy for you to say.
Charles, how concerned
are you with calories?
Very concerned.
Keto is basically
what they're made for,
so a high‐fat,
low‐carb diet.
You're eating good,
plant‐based fats.
It's basically like
tricking your body
into burning fat
for fuel.
It's low‐carb diet.
Yes.
Yeah, it's basically
a low‐carb diet.
How much is this?
$7.99.
It retails for $7.99.
‐How much?
‐$7.99.
What's it cost you
to make it?
The average cost between
the four flavors is $1.86.
That's not bad.
Where are you selling them at?
Southern California,
currently. Um...
Mostly
in health food stores?
Mostly in health food stores,
exactly, yeah.
Herjavec:
What are your sales, Holly?
In 2017, our net sales
was $270,000.
Cuban: Not bad.
And this year, to date,
we're at $182,000.
So you doubled, basically.
Yes.
What's your background?
Are you an exercise person?
Yes. I did crazy
hardcore sports growing up.
Not as crazy as this guy.
But I was a ski racer,
so I had a lot of injuries
from sports,
and a keto diet was something
I got turned onto
with lowering inflammation
in the body and the brain.
Sugar and carbs really can make
you feel like crap, honestly.
I was in a really bad
car accident when I was 17.
Ever since then, my body has
never felt the way it should,
and Billie contacted me
and she says,
"You got to try
this new thing."
I did it.
My back pain is gone.
O'Leary: Why are you worth
$2.5 million?
You've asked $250,000
for 10%.
What's the plan?
Did I mention...
No.
...that we partnered
with the official incubator
for the largest beverage company
in the world recently?
Who is that?
Coke, L. A. Libations
as an incubator.
Well, why are you worth
$2.5 million?
They're a strategic partner.
So, they give us ‐‐
What did you give them?
15%.
15%, you gave up
to the incubator?
Yep.
Cuban: That's a lot
for an incubator.
‐Yeah.
‐That's like...
We felt like they were
a really good partner for us
because they come ‐‐
They better be a damn good
partner for you.
They've been awesome.
Then what do
you need us for?
I feel like having a lot of
good people in the mix
to make great decisions is
the best thing you can do.
Put yourself in our shoes.
Why would you even listen
to someone saying,
"Give me $250,000 to get
less equity than someone else
who's offering similar expertise
that I gave for free"?
We don't come
from this industry.
We took a huge chance.
I mean, I quit a full‐time job,
I moved across the country ‐‐
O'Leary:
I got a question for you.
I know incubator deals
inside out.
Is there a royalty or
a commission on your deal?
Every one I've seen has one.
Um, so, the commission is
anything above $10,000,
then they get back
commission.
So ‐‐
‐Only what they bring in?
Only what they bring in,
correct, yes.
So, wait a minute ‐‐
you're well over $10,000 now.
What commission are you paying
on your sales?
We ‐‐ Since we have no money,
essentially,
we have actually deferred that
until they reach ‐‐
What is the
percentage amount?
Herjavec: Oh, hang on!
But how much
do you owe them?
What is the percentage amount
that you have to give them?
We just started our deal
with them, so...
Yeah.
Guys, don't make me
peel you like an onion.
Just tell me the number.
I guess I'm not understanding
the question.
Mm.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Holly and Billie seem unsure
about the terms of the deal
they've made with the incubator
they enlisted
to help their keto shake
company, Cave Shake.
I guess I'm not understanding
the question.
Okay, the question is,
what percentage of sales
are you giving to them?
What accounts
did they bring?
They have not brought in
any accounts.
We just started with them.
You're asking
for real money.
A quarter of a million dollars
is real money, okay?
Sure.
I always look at what's leaking
from the deal behind me.
I'm just looking at
the $400,000 to $500,000
you're gonna do this year
and the challenges
you're gonna have ‐‐
We're gonna do $750,000
this year at least,
even with launching
our pre‐orders just now.
Well,
if you're gonna do that,
why are you leaving the risk
of getting diluted?
Turn around
and whack that incubator.
Get rid of them.
I can't stand another guy
getting a royalty
when Mr. Wonderful's
not wetting his beak.
That's crazy.
‐Are you making an offer?
No, I'm not.
I'm out.
‐Billie.
‐Yep.
It tasted bad to me.
I find the branding
a little confusing,
and I really didn't know
what keto was.
It's a lot of information.
I'm not sure that
I get that from the name.
Totally.
I'm out.
Thank you so much.
Charles, you and I
are both on eternal diets.
Every day is
a diet struggle, right?
Yes.
Would you drink this?
Uh, well, two of
the flavors, I liked,
and two of them I did not like,
in fairness.
But I don't see
the nutritional value...
Oh, man. Whoo!
...as far as ‐‐
Like, it might
be good for you.
No, I hear you.
I'm talking about as far as
the stuff you need
to play sports.
You need great energy.
Well, that is energy.
That's great energy.
I think it's ‐‐
It's loaded with MCTs,
which are the best‐burning fuel
in our bodies.
I appreciate your energy.
The product, I like.
But there's just too much work
to do with you guys.
For that reason, I'm out.
Greiner:
I like what you're doing.
I personally follow
a more paleo diet,
sometimes keto
if I want to lose weight.
The only thing
that kind of stops me
is it's a lot of calories,
a little bottle,
and I'm not really the person
who likes to drink
their calories, versus eat them.
So I don't think
it's the right product for me.
I'm out.
Charles,
what are you gonna do?
I ‐‐ I‐I tell you what...
Yeah.
Uh‐oh.
I will give you
the $250,000.
‐Oh!
‐What?!
What?
But...
O'Leary: Hang on.
20%.
‐Oh.
‐$250,000.
That's not crazy
at all.
Would you come down
to 14%?
‐14%?!
‐[ Laughing ] 14%?
That's a long way down.
[ Laughter ]
And so, you've already
gave somebody 15%
who didn't put a dime in.
Yep! Yippie‐aye‐oh.
I actually think
my offer's fair.
What did you like
about this business
that you would actually
make an offer like that?
I've struggled with my weight
since I retired.
I would like to be involved
with a product
that helps people
lose weight.
You know, and listen,
let's get one thing straight.
Anytime
it comes to investing,
it's great to have
a great product,
but you're really
investing in people,
and I like you two.
O'Leary: So, what are you
gonna do?
Thanks, Charles.
I like you, too.
$250,000, 20%.
Best friend of 20 years,
talk to her every day.
Trust her more than anybody
on the planet, so...
And?
Well, you better
talk to me right now.
[ Laughter ]
You're staying at 20%?
There's no budging with that?
I think my offer's fair.
I don't think we're willing
to give away that much equity,
but...
What?!
Yeah.
‐It's Charles Barkley!
‐Are you kidding?!
I know!
We're, like...
Barkley: Well...
I want it.
Yeah?
Are you sure you can't
come down to, like, 18%?
O'Leary: No!
You got an offer for a quarter
of a million dollars here.
Are you saying no?
You want to do it?
I do. I think he'll help us
kill it with the athletes.
Holly?
Holly, Holly.
Give me the code word.
Are we good?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
‐All right.
‐There we go!
Aw, yeah!
‐Congratulations.
‐Man!
O'Leary: Everybody
has to sell Holly.
[ Laughs ]
Congratulations.
Let's kill it.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thanks, Lori, for all the help.
‐Good job, CB.
See, I can see you
losing weight already.
Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
Congrats, big dog.
Thank you, man.
Oh, my God,
that was crazy.
[ Laughs ]
I love Charles!
I love him.
Oh, my God.
What a nice guy.
Come on!
That guy's amazing!
You know what?
They were fun.
You know what, Charles?
They got great personality,
great energy.
Yep, yep.
And, you know,
people need ‐‐
especially now,
as I've gotten older,
it sucks trying
to lose weight.
[ Laughing ]
Yeah, I know.
So you need every shortcut
you can get.
Charles, you didn't even know
what a keto diet was
until they came in.
I still don't know
what it is.
Greiner: I'll tell you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Cheers to "Shark Tank"
for 10 amazing seasons.
Since our episode aired
in 2014,
we've done over $6 million
in total sales.
Our advice to anyone
out there with an idea
is to grab some people who
believe in you and go for it,
because you never know
how far it'll take you.
All: Cheers, "Shark Tank"!
Narrator:
Next up is a way to look stylish
while staying comfortable.
I got to tell you, man,
you're a funny dude.
Oh, thank you.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Gary Falkenburg.
I'm Danh Tran. We are from
Long Beach, California.
And we are...
Both: Butter Cloth!
Sharks,
we're seeking $250,000
for 10% interest
in our company.
Listen, I always hated
wearing a dress shirt.
They are stiff,
they are scratchy.
That's why I invented
Butter Cloth,
the shirt that
make you feel like
you are wearing
your favorite T‐shirt
but still look like
you are fully employed.
Butter Cloth's a unique fabric
made of 100% natural,
sustainable,
long‐fiber cotton.
But don't take
my word for it.
Let's bring in our long‐fiber
in‐house scientist,
Metta World Peace.
‐Oh, no.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, there goes
the neighborhood.
Oh, my goodness.
What's up, Sharks?
[ Laughter ]
How are you Sharks doing?
It's so good to be here.
As your in‐house Butter Cloth
long‐fiber cotton scientist,
it's my job to ensure
that every shirt maintains
its six‐way stretch
and breathability.
Watch this.
Okay. Here we go.
[ Laughs ]
"Slamma Jamma."
They used to call me Shaq
in the whiskey.
[ Grunts ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, now...
Hey, that was close.
It wasn't like yours.
[ Laughs ]
But not every day you can see
a dunk like that
in a shirt like this.
[ Laughs ]
Falkenburg: Butter Cloth feels
like you're wrapped in a hammock
in the Caribbean
under a palm tree,
but looks like you're giving
a keynote at NASA.
Let's put it this way.
When you are wearing
Butter Cloth shirts,
anything is possible.
Let's do this.
‐Here we go.
Run this way.
Ready? Go.
Aah! Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
Now, who would like
to join the team
and make the world
a softer place to live?
Hey, Sharks, you got to
feel it to believe it.
Give me one second.
You have a very good model.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
This is for you,
and this is in order.
‐Thank you.
Oh, it feels so nice!
Very soft.
Yeah.
Oh, it's like
a cotton shirt.
Perfect for you,
big fella.
All right. Appreciate it
Nice job.
It's 100% cotton?
100% cotton.
Guys, you're a very
eclectic‐looking group.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just saying,
I'm just saying.
How did you
come together?
Want me to start?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll start.
So, I have a background.
In college,
I majored in math.
Obviously, I went to the NBA,
but I'm very into marketing,
'cause I only want to get
involved in things
I can market, you know?
And when I put
this shirt on,
I was like, "Wow, it's perfect.
It's right up my alley.
It's athletic, I can run
and play basketball in it,
and the sweat goes away,
and it doesn't wrinkle,
and I'm like,
"I want to be involved."
And, Danh,
how did you meet Gary?
Falkenburg:
I have another friend of mine
who's actually the C. O. O.
of Butter Cloth now ‐‐ Bob ‐‐
and Bob had asked me
to come out and help him
with some of his sales
and marketing.
I watched this guy
closely.
Danh is
the most dedicated,
unbelievably
remarkable person
I've ever met in my life.
Danh, tell us your story.
Tran: I grew up in Vietnam.
My mom and my dad run
a tailor shop in Vietnam,
and when I was 10,
I making my own clothes.
My mom pull me aside, say,
"Fashion business is
very, very poor career.
I want you to be
a lawyer or a doctor."
But my dream is
want to come America
to be a fashion designer.
So I have a big decision
to make ‐‐
whether I make my parent happy
or follow my heart.
So I decided to apply for
fashion school, which is Otis.
It costs $120,000.
Wow.
Unfortunately,
I can't afford it.
And my first job
in fashion business
was working for Mattel,
making clothes for Barbie dolls.
[ Laughs ]
And then I work there
for five years,
learn a lot,
save every dollars,
and then I apply for Otis,
and then finally,
I get my B. A. degree
in fashion.
I'm very lucky to work
with Affliction clothing.
I was a head designer
for them for 10 years.
So, you're the real deal.
I'm the real deal.
Hey, so, let me ask you
a question.
This feels amazing.
Thank you.
So, how much
is this shirt?
It costs from $98 to $118.
And where are
you selling them?
We strictly online
right now.
100% online.
Only online? And what does
it cost you to make one?
Costs are from between
$20 to $25.
And that is landed.
How much have you sold?
Seven months, we do
over $500,000 in sales.
‐Wow.
Good for you.
How are you reaching
the public?
Uh, right now,
strictly everything online
through
either Facebook ‐‐
How do people
find you online?
Facebook or Instagram.
Are you buying those ads?
We have a digital
marketing company.
How much money
have you spent
running the company
since November?
I invested
in the company,
so far, is $240,000
with my own money.
I quit my job,
I sold my house,
and I cashed out
my 401(k).
‐Wow.
‐You're all‐in.
‐I'm all‐in.
You're basically selling it
for $100 each.
They cost you what
to make on average?
$20 to $25 ‐‐ landed.
Okay, so you've got $75
to play with,
and you're acquiring customers
at what price?
Right now, about $40.
Whoa!
Ooh.
What are you gonna do
with the $250,000?
Falkenburg: Well,
actually 2/3 of it
is gonna be going into
additional inventory
and about 1/3 of it
into additional marketing.
Are you bringing the marketing
in‐house or are you...
That's what our goal is.
That's what we need
some advice on.
There are people
that are extremely good
at reducing
customer acquisition costs.
They're not inexpensive, but
I think for what you're doing,
you're gonna definitely
need one of them,
because that's how
you're gonna survive.
But you're missing
that piece right now.
I'm out.
Obviously, you've got
a customer‐acquisition cost
that's less than the margin
on each shirt.
And so the more cash
you have for advertising,
the more you can make.
But yet, you want to put more
into inventory.
That money is more valuable
for advertising...
Marketing.
...than it is for more SKUs
and refreshing SKUs.
Preach it, Mark.
He is so right.
Yeah, that's a challenge.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Greiner: I've learned a lot
in the last couple of years
about the clothing business,
all really by happenstance,
because I just decided
I wanted to make the clothes
that I was wearing
on "Shark Tank"
the last couple of years,
and so many people
have been asking me
for the outfits
I was wearing
that I already have
my feet into that,
and I just don't think
it would be fair to you
to take on another one.
So I'm out.
‐Thank you, Lori.
Guys, I do know the clothing
business is cutthroat,
and I'm not willing at this
point to put up the money,
so I'm out.
‐Okay. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
One Shark left.
Robert, what are you doing?
Tran: I just want
to say that, you know,
I put everything
on this company,
and I just want to be here,
make a deal.
Yeah, I ‐‐ I like it.
The material's incredible,
and the fit looks great.
I love your story, Danh,
how you came to America.
‐Thank you.
‐I know a lot about this space.
I made a couple investments that
have done really well for me.
Mm‐hmm.
One of them is Tipsy Elves.
So I like
the online strategy,
and I think that the guys
that I'm working with
and the ladies
can really help you do
a better job online.
I can't do it for 10%.
And I know how risky it is.
I'll give you the $250,000,
but I want 25%.
Um...
♪♪
Robert...
Would you do, um...
$250,000 for 20%?
No. I‐I‐I can't do it for 20%.
It's a lot of work.
In my mind,
I was gonna go with 35%.
Those were the words
coming out of my mouth,
and for some reason,
I went to 25%.
I just feel
I'm a quarter partner.
Let's talk ‐‐ Want to talk about
it for, like, five seconds?
Can you give us, like,
five seconds?
No, no, no, just...
‐Sure.
‐Okay, go.
Go for it.
This is the guy.
Um...
♪♪
I accept your offer,
Robert.
Cuban:
Congratulations, Danh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That's
the best reaction ever!
That's awesome, man.
I really want
to try this shirt.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Congratulations.
Tran: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I didn't even know
Metta could sew.
[ Laughter ]
I'm great at it.
I'm a scientist.
We got it!
Ahh!
Whoo!
We did it!
We got it!
[ Laughs ]
Yay!
This is a dream come true.
"Shark Tank" is big help,
and just America ‐‐
I'm living the dream.
♪♪